on est dans un véhicule de la police
espagnole c'est la Mossos d'Esquadra et
en fait ça c'est un véhicule pour venir
piloter toutes les opérations spéciales
qu'on peut venir à voir lors de
manifestations lors de rassemblement de
personnes et en fait ici je suis à la
place de l'opérateur l'opérateur il fait
quoi il a accès à énormément de caméras
avec les caméras sur le véhicule les
caméras autour du véhicule et
l'opérateur il va venir afficher tout ce
que le chef le commandant lui demande
d'afficher qui est devant alors le
commandant il est juste sur la place
avant il a accès aux écrans pour dire
bah tiens affiche-moi ça affiche-moi le
drone pour voir les mouvements de foot
pour voir ce qui se passe on a également
le même poste qui est juste à côté on va
voir probablement un deuxième opérateur
qui va venir travailler ici ce qui est
très cool et bien c'est d'avoir la
chance de pouvoir venir ici le voir sur
un salon alors d'un point de vue
purement technologique on a des ordis
ici on a une configuration un peu
classique avec un moniteur on a du
Lenovo à droite et à gauche très content
de pouvoir vous montrer également
comment est-ce qu'on vient apporter la
technologie pour des usages très précis
des usages de sécurisation parce que
vous êtes bluffé par ce genre
d'installation bien évidemment et puis
on passe un grand coucou à toutes les
forces de l'ordre qui nous regardent et
je sais que vous êtes nombreux